Okay. Welcome everyone. This is the largest we ever had for this course of multimodal machine
learning. I'm very excited to start this new semester. This is probably about sixth time
we teach this course, but we made some changes this year. This would be the first time that
this course is recorded completely remotely, it's done completely remotely. If at any point
you have a question, I very welcome questions. Since it is a very large group of people,
what I will ask each of you is to type questions. This will work much better. So type any questions.
We have the TAs who are monitoring this. They may, in fact, answer directly the question
if it is via chat, or if not, then it will notify me and we can address that. So I want
to start right now. This season, we have five TAs that are going to work with us for this
and I'm very happy to have all five that were handpicked to be people who have experience
in multimodal either by taking this course and or doing research directly on this topic.
Paul is TA and at the same time will be guest lecturer on a few lectures, specifically reinforcement
learning and I'm very excited that he accepted to give a few of these lectures. The rest of
time will be me giving lectures and at the end we'll have a few more guest lecturer.
We have Prakhar, also Martin, Shikib and Torsten. I think at least right now we have Martin and
Paul who are somewhere in that list of 120 plus people who are currently on this. So yeah,
so today my goal is first to share my passion about multimodal. I'm definitely passionate on
this topic and you will see it through my lecture. I want to give you a definition of multimodal,
what is multimodal, a historical view and also share these five technical challenges
that are involved in many of the multimodal research and give you details on the syllabus.
What is multimodal? And normally at this point I will try to get answers from you
and I did not manage to get the Paul's functionative zoom to work right now so it would be without
the Paul. But what is multimodal? What is a definition? Sometimes we can think of multimodal
as from a mathematical perspective, a multimodal could be seen in fact one of the first
although not the first one but one of the first definition of multimodal was really
multimodal distribution, multimodal mode of a distribution like the peak. But often when we
think of multimodal it is a lot more related to sensory modalities, the sound, the touch
and the speech, what you see and so all of these are the sensory. I myself have done a lot of research
over the years on a part of this which is the subset of these modalities although I'm excited
in multimodal machine learning in general. I have focused myself on the subset of them
and three of them that we will be focusing a lot more in this course but in general that
are very central to communication. I call them the 3v of communication, verbal, vocal and visual,
what you see, how you say it and also the visual, the behavior. So verbal, the words,
how you phrase them but also the intent behind the words are very important. The vocal is one
part is the process, the process is related to what you say, the words, how you say the words,
that's one aspect but there's also what's called vocal expression like a laughter or a
pause fillers, all of these are part of vocal, they're kind of the nonverbal aspect of visual.
So this is one aspect of this and then the third one is visual, the gestures, the B gestures like
I'm doing body language, other proximics in the virtual world mean almost something different.
And if you ask me one of the important QI look in all communication is I guess,
it's a very important Q both from communication perspective but also conclusively when you're
talking and thinking. Finally facial expression very important, so that these are three examples
in a second I'm going to give you a much larger number of that but before I give in the specific
of different modalities there's a difference between, you've heard maybe the term sometimes
multimodal and multimedia and you're like oh what's the difference, a modality and a medium
are different, all the very related, the modality is the way in which something happened in this
experience, this is in the sense almost the content of it, the medium is the mean in the way it is
stored and communicated, so you can see there is a big relationship in this audio being
a medium you could say and the vocal being a modality, over the years multimodal and multimedia
had so much overlap that people started using the terms back and forth and so you will see them use
multimedia and multimodal but I just wanted to give you originally how these came from and when
you think of multimodal you have to think of multidisciplinary, this is something that comes
from many different fields all bringing together and in a sense it's almost AI coming together
because there's the speech, the vision, the language, there's also maybe the tactile and the robotics,
there's the aspect of learning and there are applications and knowledge to gain from medical
and psychology, so I mentioned natural language, visual and auditory or verbal, visual and vocal,
there's also the touch, if you look at these days we also have to do sensors, a lot of sensors to
the cell phone, you have in medical field EEG and you also have infrared cameras sometimes in some
sensors and we also have MRI, the course as I mentioned we'll focus on language and vision
as two of the building blocks for a lot of our examples but a lot of the work we talk about
will in fact also have application other modalities and as often as possible I will try to bring these
other example modalities in there, so the historical view I just want because sometimes you talk
with students and sometimes we with the world of archive and we kind of think that the science
everything that's more than five or ten years old is too old to read so I would like to think of
multimodal as something that really evolved over the years and I think there's a lot of value in
looking behind, looking at previous work, from my experience in multimodal, from my study of it,
there's four eras of multimodal, there is the era of behavioral, a lot of the work there was
psychology and inspiring communication, inspired, I will give you one a few example on this very
interesting work, I strongly suggest to look at some of this early work and then there's something
magic in late, in middle of late 80s where suddenly it's no more just looking at multimodal behavior
from maybe a psychological or linguistic perspective but certainly looking at computational
approach, one of them is looking at individual speech recognition and sometime in 2000 and I
give you like probably one of the reasons for that but there's a switch where it's not just looking
at a human in a computer but suddenly multimodal look at multiple people and their social interaction
and so there is a lot of emphasis in social interaction and in 2010-ish then there's a suddenly move
in looking at those neural architecture, like the renewal of neural architectures that started
almost 2006-2007 but really had a big grasp around 2010. The course is focusing a lot more on that
part but I think it's healthy to look at it more generally as well so if you have to read one and
it's hard to pick only one person to read but if you had to look at this era and he's done work
in the 1990s but I'm just putting someone 80s, David McNeal, I love his work very much on language
and gesture and he's done a lot of interesting work that looking at gesture are in fact a display
of people's thoughts and so it's more than just something that I accompany the speech it is a clear
deputation of the thoughts and there's a very interesting debate around language and gestures
around there and our own faculty here at CMU just think I said work very closely with David
McNeal back in the days. I will say there's this magic moment where suddenly we went from
we went from psychological linguistic to psychology and linguistic to more
computational approach and I think one of these is that really sparked interest is the megahertz
effect. I'm going to play the videos maybe some of you have seen in the past the megahertz effect
so you have to listen and watch the video so if you're looking at something at the same time
it's not going to work so this time you need to look at the video and listen I'm going to play
two flips and you have to see if you hear something different in both cases.
Okay so this was the first slip so hopefully you heard something repeated over and over it sounds
really simple. I'm going to play it again not the same clip a second clip and listen if you hear
something different. What's really interesting for the few of you who didn't bother to even look
at it you probably in fact heard the same thing both times and the reason for that is it's exactly
the same audio clip it's exactly the same audio clip in both cases the only difference is the video
in both of them. In one case you probably the first one heard something closer to bah bah bah
and the second is pa pa pa. So you can see that suddenly it's very exciting something like oh my
god we were doing all this work on speech recognition there was an interesting work in the 80s on this
and like but then and like oh but maybe the old reason that this was not working well it was that
we needed to have both I'll do a video together and that's why in the the next space is computational
I think suddenly it what drove a lot of it one of the thing not the only thing but one of the
main thing that drove the computational era is this audio visual speech recognition this idea that
to recognize things you need to be able to look and hear and look at the same time one thing that
was interesting during this era is that it turned out that although it is effectively helping it looks
like audio and visual could help together in a few cases it turned out in the case of speech
recognition there's a lot of redundancy both signals are encoding the same thing which is great
which made things in fact more robust and so one of the things to take home for all the research on
other videos or speech recognition is that sometimes bringing the two modalities together the goal
may be to have something more robust and you can have redundant information in both modality
you could have also complementary like you need to have both modalities to be able to infer
like the far far far but in in most cases you can also find that only one modality may be sufficient
now at the same time when this old work happened in audio visual speech recognition in the world
of human computer interaction there's suddenly a lot of interest in multimodal because human
how will a human ever interact with the computer it should be the same way as the human interact
with each other and human interact with each other with two multiple modalities so there's a lot of
interest at this point to build computers now these days we almost see it as a reality coming up
with these different interphase Alexa being one of them but now we have these assistants
but there we're talking about more than 20 plus years ago there was already this dream of this and
one of the a sub dream of that was effective computing where it's not only you talk with the
robot but there's also the aspect of emotion and feeling that will be able to perceive and generate
and model and if you wonder why emotions emotions are key to decision making there's a lot of work
in this and a lot of literature on this topic but if for decision making emotions are key
but they are also key for other things like sharing emotion sharing how you're feeling so
their emotions are important a different aspect the the third thing there was multimedia these
happen all around the same time a little bit later I will see multimedia computing multimedia
computing was the idea of all of these video that was being created digitally and can we understand
its content so that we cannot just we don't we don't just research thing based on keywords
but we can use the content of the video and it was a very big landmark project that was almost 15
years at Carnegie Mellon Alex Hoffman was one of the co-PI on this so this is fun this is great
because at that point it was the beginning of the internet now it sounds so obvious with things like
YouTube or even Facebook and other platform that we want to search videos but this was really at
the beginning of it and so they want to look at the content inside the video the speech image
and the language in it so this is 2000 and then suddenly we go ahead and it's what I would call
the interaction era at this point we want to model human-human interaction as well and one
landmark project I will say is the AMI project in early 2000 they recorded meetings moving together
people talking to each other so it was no more just human computer and it was a lot more
looking at people how they interact together there was a follow-up to that also with faculty
at CMU chill by the way if you know Ben Joe from Montreal's and his brother Sammy was in fact on
the AMI project I think it was as opposed back in the days I think he was recently at Google if I
remember correctly um Sammy so just to give an example another very big important one for everybody
who has an iPhone you know about Siri but Siri came from this multimodal project that it was a
darker-funded project called Kalo about this personal assistant this whole idea of bringing information
together and around the same time social signal processing although the term itself started in
the US it had a big momentum in Europe around that time so a lot of very interesting project
and then suddenly and then suddenly we come into the deep learning and why is the deep learning era
so important for multimodal because there's some landmark work and I listed some of them
that landmark work but really the key enabler why suddenly the way we went from multimodal research
before to a brand new paradigm of multimodal research it is from at least four different
reasons the first two I I will say generic reason for many research topics and the last two I think
I'm a little bit more specific the first one is that suddenly that we had a much larger number
of multimodal data set I talk about the AMI data set there's a lot of other one
I do visual emotional challenges being other example but suddenly there's a move towards
much larger data set so that's one point and the other point that you probably heard
often and over and over is also about faster computer and GPUs that allowed us to revisit
theories and models back from the 90s and restarted them now in this larger scale
scenarios and so yes these were definitely very important but I think what really made the
difference is two things if you think of multimodal and specifically look at language vision and maybe
audio as well vision is was a very high dimensional and and many modalities have the same issue
very high dimensional and the way to represent it was I've always been somewhat of a challenge
there are some very interesting features that were like more local in space like CIF feature back in
2000 but suddenly with neural representation and the revisiting of convolutional suddenly you take
these very high dimensional representation and put them in a one vector or one representation
that is much smaller that allowed to take both the spatial information and the texture
information and encode that in that one vector so that was very nice that happened one landmark
paper in 2011 if I remember correctly and around the same time a lot of interesting approaches that
were studied in the past about a distributional hypothesis meaning the meaning of a word can be
approximated by the words surrounding it got revisited by researchers around the world but
specifically by Google researchers was one of the landmark word with word to back and so then
you could take what was very discreet very discreet elements like a word and suddenly you were able
to encode them into something that like a vector representation some people would call the word
to back vectors so now we had something that was very discreet and we can put it in a vector
representation we have an image that was high dimensional you can put it in a vector and then
in speech I would say these there was a lot of work in the past and they had already found
very useful representations that could already be used although there you see some newer one
recently but they're still already at a good understanding looking at the frequency domain
looking at spectrogram or if and how people are hearing and looking at MFCC so all these modalities
now are all on the same similar and they're not exactly the same space because you have to remember
the kind of noise you see in an image is very different from the kind of noise you see in words
like in a word you may have a mistake in the way something has been transcribed or something like
this but in the words we're talking about pixel change of textures so very different model of noise
and so it's not that these space are equivalent but they are a lot closer so we went from very
heterogeneous to less heterogeneous it's still different space but they are a lot a bit closer
and so that really brought in the multimodal deep learning and some of the polar papers
to try to study these and that's what we're going to study in this course today
so when we study multimodal you're probably wondering like is it why do I do study multimodal
machine learning why not just studying machine learning I mean if it's in the name and probably
everything we study in machine learning is exactly what we need in multimodal when we started teaching
this course and I like more than six years ago the goal was to study what exists in machine learning
and what exists in multimodal research and try to identify what is the core challenges what other
core technical challenges in multimodal that have been understudied in machine learning it doesn't
mean they're never studied but they've been kind of understudied in machine learning and so we identified
five of these core challenges and I'm going to highlight them during this lecture today and
we're going to use it as a structure for this course we're going to go way beyond that eventually
because this survey for example was a survey of three years ago so but it's interesting if you do
a survey and you talk about taxonomy of research it's interesting that although the there's a lot
of new papers that came in the taxonomy some of it is still very relevant these days and a lot of
it is still relevant I think we can always expand it's a good starting point I think when you're
studying multimodal so let me go in this and study what those core challenges are right now I'm not
going to give I'm going to give another view and we're going to spend the next 15 weeks together
looking in the details and looking at state of the eye that way go go beyond that so but two of
the core challenges I think for many problems but also for multimodal is how do you bring verbal
vocal and visual and at a first level is very important and I think everybody who's used or
work nowadays days with deep neural representation or networks really understand the challenge of
representation learning and so I think there's some very key aspect that are true for in general
of representation learning but in multimodal I'm going to share with you a few core challenges
related to representation if you ask me why does this one challenge that is very multimodal is
alignment and I'm going to give a little bit more a little bit more details in a second looking at
synchrony but let me talk about multimodal and I have a dream and I had this dream for a while
and this dream is that I could learn a representation where if I say I like it or I'm a happy face or
joyful tone that the representation will encode that the similarity or if I'm tense or if I'm
or if I'm surprised that these will be able that my representation will encode that at some level
and this is a dream that I had for a while and I will say we're a lot closer to that but back in
the days this dream comes as more than 15 years old this dream but what happened in this 2010-11
and plus is that suddenly that dream become a lot more reality and what what happened is that they
people were suddenly bold to learn joint representation representation where you see an object is a visual
representation and then you see you you see you see some language associated with this so maybe a
red car or a enthusiastic per speaker or some so you have a kind of a description and so you have
some kind of paired data and so a Georgia representation allows you to learn this one space where both
of them will live together and that sounded like almost impossible before but now with this work
and now we're seeing a lot more of that we got this we got to see these joint representation see
very important milestone and one of the example I'm going to show in the next slide is here's what
they did and I love it and I always talk about this one example is that they learn back in the days
they learn to a pair of datasets where you have pair image and description and they learn a joint
representation a representation could be just a vector and what's great by having it joint is
that suddenly you can take any sentence and and if the model was successful in training you can
take any of these sentences and encode it pass it through to your model and suddenly get your
representation your vector and you could do it similarly with any image and both will be in the
same space in the same kind of representation and what can you do if you do this is great what did
they do they did and they train the model and then they test and then what they do they take an image
of a blue car blue car and then they go and encode it like kind of get a vector out of it with their
model that they had trained another data and then they take the word blue and then they also encode
it and then they create the word red and also encode it and then they do have it metric which is
beautiful the blue car the image of a blue car minus blue plus red you get a new vector and then
you can sample from that like your nearest neighbor like looking you know all of the training data
or you could have a calibration data set for that and that's really interesting that suddenly you
get images of red car you could do it for colors and then they did it for day and night so you take
a palace and then do it at night flying and plus sailing so although and we're going to discuss
these issues I mean it doesn't mean that arithmetic is true every time there's cases this will fail
but just the fact that it worked in some cases was very exciting I think this was for me a big
relevant relation so so then suddenly you have the chance to have multimodal representation so
representation the challenge can be formalized as learning how to represent and summarize multimodal
data in a way that explored the complementarity and redundancy if you remember in audiovisual
speech recognition they turned out there's a lot of redundancy between the two between what I say
and my lips there's a lot like my visor my phoneme what you hear are similar to my visor more like my
lips contour so this is redundancy and you want to take advantage of that redundancy maybe to be
more efficient and more robust but you also want to do complementarity like the mega effect if two
things by themselves are not sufficient like and you need to bring them together when you think of
representation many people think of joint representation you take two modalities and you force them
together in one representation one vector space there is and I would like to make you think a
little bit outside the box a little bit with coordinated representation that's a different way to think a
little bit about representation learning where instead of bringing everything together what you
will do is bring each of them so language you have that representation and then you will have
visual and you you have its own space and instead of forcing them to be in the same one you will
keep them but you're going to coordinate a subspace a sub part of it you're going to coordinate
and coordination you should see it as a spectrum coordination is that as a spectrum between that
so what do I mean is that at one end the coordination is so strong that they are equal you're forcing
it to be language representation being called to visual representation that's one end of it sorry
at that point it's mostly a joint representation at the other end they're separate representation
you don't coordinate at all and then you have a spectrum in between one example is you could say
I'm not going to make them equal but I'm going to make them correlated so it's not as much as
they call but close an example of that is CCA canonical correlation analysis you could use that
or you could go and say from all my representation I'm going to bring together only a subset of each
representation there's some items I want very close to each other and for the rest I will let you
let each modality separate and let them by themselves and we'll study different version of these coordinated
representation as I mentioned one thing that is core to multi model is alignment like synchrony
I talk and speak and gesture at the same time you want to be able to align speech and gesture as
an example when I say it's very specific to to multi model alignment is in fact what I the generic
term is multi view multiple view of the same data so multi model it could be seen as a specialization
of multi view learning where the the views are modalities but another way of multi view is to
also look at multilingual multiple languages these are all multi view problems multi model
multilingual and so that's why if some of you have studied machine translation you will see the
problem of alignment because this is a multi view you want to be in alignment you want to be able to
have elements of one modality like words or objects and be able to align them together and
synchronize and align them some people will say when its language and images will save them to
ground them as an example and when you do this there's two types of alignment there's the problem
of explicit alignment or implicit alignment explicit alignment means your goal your last function your
your task is to align thing together let's say I give you a corpora with a bunch of images and a
bunch of text and I say match them together or a video and a cooking recipe it's a video of the
recipe and a cooking I want to align that or a wiki like to do do it yourself video and the
instruction that kind of alignment that's explicit alignment the last function what you're optimizing
is going to be the alignment in many cases the alignment is just an intermediate step like the
the real last function may be another task it may be about generating text from an image
and so you go from the image to generating text and in the middle as a latent process
you do implicit and for people who work on this topic the example of that would be an
attention model will be an example of implicit or latent alignment these days we talk about
self attention and transformers will all be in this thread but there's often cases where you go is
I give you two videos and I want to align them together that's probably the most visual of the
example I could give so here's a you have very these videos originally were a different time
number of different granularity they're not exactly the same but you're doing your best match to
align them and you could I could have give you an image and you say hey the task is to align every
words with every object or every possible word that you can with any object in the image but in
many cases the alignment is not explicit but really the task is just the generation of language
and implicitly as a latent state you would do it so this is representation and we're we will
spend about two full weeks four lectures on representation I think we have at least two lectures on alignment
these are very very core aspect of the course but then from there there's a branch from alignment
there's a branch you either you always almost always have representation almost always have
alignment but then there's a branch are you doing translation or are you doing fusion there are
few examples where both are happening at the same time but it's it's it's often and their translation
and fusion is about what is your loss function what is your loss function in the case of translation
what what is are you trying to do and translation is translating from one modality to another
for example translating from an image to text like for image captioning fusion the loss function
is not creating generating one of the modality in the case of fusion you bring all the modalities
together to be able to infer something else something high level like the recognizing the emotion or
detecting an event in the video so the fusion will be different and will bring different approaches
than translation so let me talk about translation at first and then talk about fusion translation
the landmark and we'll talk a little bit more on tuesday about this but one of really the landmark
work on translation was image captioning and i discussed that more on on on tuesday um but there's
more than that there's different type of translations and one of them that i like quite a bit is this
example in this example what you will see is on the uh i don't know if it's right or left for you but
on one side the input side what you have is from the video we're only going to get the transcript of
what has been said and the audio stream like the acoustic the vocal of the prosody only take that
and the goal is to generate the behaviors and the behaviors the visual gesture you want to generate
you're going to want to generate two types the speaking gesture if someone is talking what what
does it look like and the second one is if someone is listening what are their gestures and so in
this video that i'm about to play um when you see the virtual human the appearance of the virtual
human was designed to look a lot like the movie that that's that's manually done and the placement
and the viewing goal was manually done but the gesture themselves of the virtual human are
all automatic uh from the system so it's a nice example uh to death them
look sorry you snotty little bastard you're honored like to ask for a recess i might
like an answer to the question judge the court will wait for an answer if lieutenant kendrick gave
an order that sontayaga wasn't to be touched and why did he have to be transferred colonel
lieutenant kendrick order the code red didn't he because that's what you told lieutenant kendrick to
do um yeah when it went bad you cut these guys loose you're on her you're on her you're on her
you've got your blog book there can't be worse a doc studio something to you colonel jessie give
you water the code red you don't have to answer that question i'll answer the question you want
answers i think i'm entitled you want answer what the truth you can't handle the truth i love that
movie very much uh um uh so yes uh this this was an example uh and this is a little bit old but now
you see a lot of these renewal um there is a speech to gesture and different project it's really
interesting to see all this work uh going but the translation is you take something text and speech
and be able to generate from that um the other so when i think of translation what it is is the
process of changing data from one modality to another but also keep the link and so and this uh where
the translation relationship can often be open and dead and subjective and that's one thing we'll
discuss also on tursday is one of the big challenge with translation which is true i i told you
alignment is related to multimodal and multi-view which is also related to machine translation
but but this is true from any translation like language to language or also like speech generation
these are all translation problem and they all come with the big challenge of evaluation
will be a big challenge when you do any translation so when you look at the translation two ways or
two approaches maybe the slightly older way would be but also very interesting way and i think you
should visit it's kind of more the non-parametric way of looking at translation where i have uh
a test time i'm going to look at like example from my uh training and maybe to like the more the
classic the most classic of these will be nearest neighbor that's the most classic non-parametric
model but the translation there's a lot of interesting work in parametric approaches trying to reduce
the number of parameters sometime also and see generalization between training and testing so
these are two example let me show one last example this one is my work is or work not my work as you
know students are the one doing the work but i'm very excited about this work about translating
from language to motion uh so i i i i'm uh originally i spent seven years of uh in uh essentialist and
i had the mini dream at that point that i could take a movie script and create a first version of
the movie just by looking at the movie script and so you can see the description the actor move
and jog or the person step forward then turn around and move forward again let me play it again
just to be sure oh i think there's a problem with the animation i apologize for that uh
anyway so this is an example i will fix this for the slide um the other uh so this is translation
but there is also the aspect of fusion where you bring the information and try to infer something
novel something new uh something about the sentiment maybe over time so fusion is probably
the oldest of the the challenges uh in fact when i started my phg a long time ago um if you ask
what was multimodal research at this point you could almost summarize it with early fusion
and late fusion and then the question was just which of the two did you use early fusion oh
oh what did you try late fusion or you try late fusion did you try early fusion so it was very early
but now these days with with the portfolio is much larger but it's still really interesting early
fusion the idea is that the modalities are going to be concatenated early on and then your model
is going to learn hopefully how to bring these together so you're kind of making it uh with the
hypothesis that you can't build uh you can't uh train or learn your process unless you bring
it up early on so that means that there's some very low level you should use early fusion when
there's some very low level multimodal uh phenomena happening that there is something very like people
are just increasing their voice and moving at the same time very low level the late fusion is
the idea that i need to do some processing internally in in one from each modality before i try to make
my fusion uh and if i try to do it too early and and you have to remember that at this point the
data sets were much smaller that that's part of the reason uh you had this so now these days there's
a lot more approaches uh to do that uh in the course a lot of the course will be on deep neural
architectures and all that it's variance but we're also going to discuss uh kernel based
approaches and the part that i personally like very much is graphical models i love their
interpretability also the fact that you can bring them in knowledge into these architectures so
i think it's good to visit them as well the last challenge that i want to discuss is co-learning
the intuition behind co-learning uh the the main intuition there is that um we talked up to now
about all of these problems where we bring all this uh multi-modal information together or that
we're translating it but there are cases where the problem the most interesting or at least for
that person the most interesting problem is unimodal it's possible the problem is unimodal by itself
let's say it's um object detection in an image i want to detect the best possible detector and
the most generalizable to any kind of label uh class label or object labels
so it's a very unimodal problem but maybe there is something from other modalities
that could help me at training time to be better in my task in my unimodal task i'm going to use
multi-modal information at the training time to help me and so that at test time i'm best i'm better
or better best and these co-learning cases are usually the most useful when there's an issue with
where there's a problem with the limited amount of data and so maybe there's not as much data
annotated yet for my task and so that's why you will see them a lot more as few-shot learning
kind of scenarios so this is co-learning and you could imagine doing it both way language could
help vision but vision could also help language and then suddenly you have this uh two-way co-learning
and this has a name and that was in the multi-view setting this was called co-training uh so co-training
with uh Tom Mitchell being one of the co-author of the original paper so so these are example of
co-learning and the big challenge with co-learning is when you have this second modality helping you
is how much pairing how strong do you know that this second modality is linked with that first
modality how strong is that link that pair pair data and for people who do machine translation
you know also like do you have a pair very strong pairing where almost every word you know what
other word uh is in the other language or which sentence and these uh the translation or you could
have it like what's could be called non-parallel or what i personally prior weekly parallel is is
the idea that you have maybe a corpus of language sentences and a corpus of french sentences english
and french sentences and then but you don't have exactly which one is which one but you know that
they're related so that's weak and you have the same in months modal you have a bunch of images
and and you're the text and you have just only at maybe at the corpus so you have a spectrum
again of being very strongly paired to weekly spare and so one example for that is how do you
learn language embedding so i'm talking right now and how do i encode my words into something that
would be useful maybe for emotion recognition and so the idea here is that i will i want to learn
this and if i have infinite amount of data i have a large amount of corpus i think probably you can
do it just from language itself but and and for text corpus like written corpus there's been a lot
of it but for spoken there's maybe let's say fewer of this there's still quite a bit but let's say
for the purpose of the example let's suppose there are few of it a few of it so then i would say but
when i speak there it's not only about my language but it's also about my gesture it's also my tone
of words so can i use it during training this extra information to be able to prove but at test
time i'm only gonna have i will only have language so the trick here is i'm going to use the the idea
of translation where i do end up taking from the verb ball and i will translate it in an
intermediate representation that will be used to finally generate the visual and so this is supposed
paired data but i will also do it with what's called a cyclic loss which they say not only did i
take something like today was a great day and try to generate the visual but that needs to be able
to regenerate what was originally there and the reason for that i want to do that is is that
internally that intermediate representation i need to be sure that it contains everything
that was in today i don't want to lose anything that's there and see if i was to do only the one way
i may end up having an intermediate representation that's a lot closer to my target and there's some
interesting work on this that shows that often these intermediate representation
are closer to the target than the source but if i putting the cyclic and suddenly you have this
so to be sure that they also look very much like the input and then at test time what's really nice
is that you can forget about the multi model and maybe on a small data set train for this on the
task like sentiment analysis or anything and what was really interesting in the results of this is
that this work almost as much as a multi model like having multi model both at training and testing
so that was really interesting so this is the high level view of five i these are not the unique
and i really welcome your feedback when you think about it and one of the reading assignment
will be this survey paper not all of it we're splitting in two but yeah think about this like
what are the interesting challenges and this is a draft of the taxonomy that came from this
example of what are the sub challenges in multi model research and what's great with multi model
research is that these examples are applicable with many applications up to now i may have emphasized
a lot more affect and emotion partially it is a good part of our research in my group isn't that
topic but if you ask me what really started the renewal the new part of multi model is really the
aspect of what some people would call language and vision research and so looking at media description
as an example is like how image captioning or video captioning and visual question answering
there's also have been very good and very strong work that if anything started earlier if you ask me
i will say affect recognition had been there for a while uh and multimedia had done a lot of work
and and there was a quite a renewal also there and in affect uh with the 2010 one multi model
and media description although you can find some example as early as 2001 for image captioning
it really started it had a big boost in 2010 11 so so this is what we are there we're here for this
kind of course that's our goal for this so my goal is to spend the next i don't know 15 20 minutes
to also go through the course syllabus and also share with you what we believe is going to be a
very engaging way of studying this research so for this i really want to go for the course
syllabus but also share with you or vision just a second or vision for this uh because
we want this to make it engaging and i know with the world of being virtual and remote it can be
challenging so the three main paradigm for this course and although the grades uh maybe not reflecting
all the importance of each of them but the but the i think all three of them are equally important
but from a grading perspective you're going to see one of them is clearly bigger and this is a
personal choice in designing this course but i think all three of them are really important one is
course lecture participation and just in the in general the course lecture i'm talking i'm talking
a lot and that's part of lecturing and i'm going to share with you um our view of how to assess
the course participation in this and we call them lecture highlights and i'm going to talk
about it in a little bit the goal was to not overwhelm you with extra homeworks but still have a way
to be sure that you both listen and understand the lectures and more importantly if you have also
questions about the lectures that you're able to share those questions so we're going to talk
about how exactly we evaluate this the other aspect is this this course one thing i should
mention this course is best suited for student in their third semester this is the best uh third
third and plus third four five six seven ten i don't know if any of you are in the 10 semester
but yeah third semester is definitely the best first semester is possible uh and i'm going to
discuss another bit but a lot of this course is the idea that you not only going to learn the basic
and the core about multi-model machine learning but i really want you also to understand and and
really understand and explore the the state of the art on this topic and so that's why i'm
calling it's a little bit more of an advanced course um so the reading assignment is one of the
learning paradigm for that and and we we taught a lot about it the initial version was let's have
every student read 30 papers this semester i don't see your facial expressions but i i can
imagine that would be a lot so what we decided to make it more interactive is to create within the
group what we call study groups these will be about nine or ten students uh working together
so that they can learn together and how it is is that we're going to give every uh for every reading
assignment we're going to give three papers and each student will have one of the paper and then
they they're going to learn about they will learn about the other papers by uh by helping each other
through some kind of chat base uh or some uh uh discussion forum to to help each other so we're
giving the details in a little bit but reading the state of the art uh papers is important and i
think that's one of the learning paradigm the core of this is the course project i i value very much
a practical learning and getting you to learn at this and i'm we're going to scaffold this problem
because this is a very big piece um one big warning for anybody on their first semester and graduate
study or undergrad student i have a warning uh for you uh and that may be true for uh later but
it's usually specifically for first year students or undergrad it's sometime uh we're really homework
driven like a homework deadline is on friday we start on wednesday or tursday the homework and then
two days you crank it and that's enough that's not that will not be true for this class uh there is
i've been very careful to reduce the number of homework but each homework this grade this course
project you can't just wait until two days before and and you need to start two weeks three weeks
in advance to work and that's why these are team projects so you work and you should plan to work
and meet with your team at the minimum once a week uh for the rest of the semester to really get
things going i'm going to give more details but of course project the goal at the end of it is to
create research that potentially could be submitted in a conference like icml uh or any of the
conferences you want now i i know when i say icml oh my god my grade is gonna will be based on me
having an icml paper accepted no no no the goal is to explore research only work maybe 15 20 percent
of the time so uh but exploration you learn a lot through that and then you can move and move so
your grade is not going to be based on like accuracy level or how good you are no uh the base is the
idea of doing the research and understanding why it works and why it does not work and we'll
discuss a little bit that we're going to really help you scaffold the whole process so this is
the idea of the course project at the high level but we're going to go in more details in a second
but uh what i wanted to share is like this course is designed don't take this class if you can't
read attentively 10 papers that's the bare minimum i'm not gonna go i will not go lower than this
right this is the lowest i'm able to go and still have a very stimulating paper course um 10 papers
that you learn if you may have questions about it that's why you have a study group you don't need
to read these paper and understand everything right away were you gonna work together for that
but you need to read them and take the time more than reading like in diagonal you really need to
read in-depth 10 papers enough to read them to explain it to your friends uh to your other people
in your study groups you should have a minimum aspect of machine learning you should know
you should have taken one of the machine learning course here at the CMU or before that
and within most of the latest machine learning there's often an aspect of deep neural network
so you should have done some experience like with like pytorch or something like this if you had
none of this this can be a challenging course for you it's not impossible but it is um uh more
challenging uh and you have to be motivated to try something new and get a very high quality
course project because that's the the cornerstone of this so we spent a lot of time over the last
six years to kind of define what would be a good way to scaffold the course project to make it
good and easy but also simulating so we made it in uh four main steps um so one is a pre-proposal
this is very soon so you already have a homework on tuesday and and it's due for next tuesday
so uh next tuesday what i'm going to talk about it in a little bit but the goal is in two weeks from
now you already have your team and we're going to help you finding teammates we have a really cool
thing uh on tuesday uh next week uh fun thing we're going to try also for teammates but by
by by um by two weeks from now you know which data set you want to work on you know which task
you're likely to work on and which teammates it's possible that you may not have teammates and
then we'll help you but most of you expect like at least 90 percent to have teams hopefully 100
percent but if not we'll help you um whoops sorry for the cursor um the then next milestone almost
a month later is the proposal at that point you had your team and uh you will do you will do your
your proposal like like that's what i'm want to work on and there's two things that are needed for
there one is a literature review so often i see students working on a topic they found one paper
oh that's so cool let me do this this and this with that one paper no i want you to take the time
read about it read other papers gather at least 10 12 maybe 15 papers around this so that's that's
what you need to and then at that point you're gonna you will look at your data set and start doing
unimodal analysis on this just to see what the data looks like too often i see people they're like
this is a data set i downloaded it i ran the code of someone else and i made a small modification
but people sometimes don't take the time to look at the data itself so i think it's very
important so that's the first step the key aspect after that is the midterm at that point you will
implement state-of-the-art in that field uh at least one may be depending on the size of your
team maybe two or three of these models you will implement them but the goal of implementing them
is not just to get like accuracy and all this what i really want is do error analysis
like really understand why are they not working what makes it like that would give you ideas
to where to go with this and so that is really important that's a key thing and finally the
fun part is like okay i have the state-of-the-art i know the previous work i know my data
now let me try two or three new ideas depending on the size of your group maybe up to four ideas
but yeah let's go new ideas i mean some of them most of them are not going to work but let's try
that's what research is about and that's what the last part of the project is so i'm very excited
about this um some guideline we strongly suggest it's another requirement but it strongly suggests
to have two modalities in your data language and vision and visual the reason for that is the course
has a big component around that and also the community has done a lot of work around that so
so i will suggest now if you realize there's some other days that that don't have it it is
possible uh to go beyond that let's say self-driving cars or uh i don't know brain imaging or something
but but let or acoustic or audio but talk with your TA uh about this or about the instructors
about me and the TA's the teams three four and five and i strongly suggest teams of four and five
we saw them as working the best we try for a while teams of one you know what happens with the team
of one the team of one is mostly someone who do already their own research and they end up like
just tweaking it for this course that does happen unfortunately and also what's really nice with the
the team is that you're gonna you will brainstorm together i get ideas so it's really good dynamic
we found that three four and five were some of the most productive team and also we we have
we'll have almost 120 students so um we also need to scale uh with this uh the project should
explore something novel on the modeling side these are the three two or three or four ideas
that you will explore and that there's a lot of beautiful deadlines coming out at the end of this
class uh i i forgot knackel if you're gonna make it that's that's a little bit tight but they will
be i ACL hkai icml if you wait a little but longer icmi face and gesture the triple yeah yeah there's
a lot of very interesting so on thursday i'm going to share some ideas also some existing
projects that were done um and uh we will share some gpu resources um for you uh it's not infinite
these resources um but we're um we'll share some of it um so you can do your project so
in the short term there are four other deadlines before the main big deadline of uh in two weeks
next on thursday i'm going to share some multi-model data set and topics and application
now you have a homework to do either you do it on friday before the labor day we can or you do it
during the labor day weekend uh but on tuesday what i need from each of you is your data set preference
your project preference what what do you want to work on what is the topic we're going to share
the instruction via piazza really soon for that um if you are and i'm going to talk about the waitlist
in a little bit later uh but that if you're on the waitlist i strongly suggest that you still
submit uh this if you really want to take the class you also submit your project preference
to that we are sure that we get everyone uh in this thursday we're gonna we'll have a really
front team formation um if you already have your team you already know these other people i won't
work with um you're you're you don't have to join but we'll have this uh it's called gaterton
we're gonna have this gaterton uh to to help with team formation and then by wednesday you should
have your team you should have this and then the task it is important a qual contribution i want
all of you to work on this and you are the best to help us monitor this so if early on at the
proposal you see that there was a this is confidential a lot of time when someone is not participating as
much is that there's another factor it's very rare that someone is not participating just because
they don't want to or something there's often other factors so the earlier you tell us the earlier we
can contact them and then work with them and often we find great solution and then things goes well
afterward but don't wait for the final by the time it's the final this is not the time to tell us hey
this person never helped this is late so do it early on here's how we we uh we uh we uh put the
schedule for uh the lectures the introduction for this week and the next two weeks after that
are both the basic where the basic building block both on the learning side for week two and on
the unimodal side for week three and then week four and five will be a lot more about representation
and we're gonna we'll start touching a little bit alignment but a lot more on representation
finally week six no lectures because this is the first big deadline and we will use the lecture
time to help you if you have any questions but I really want to work you you work hard on your
at this point week so we these are the intermediate deadlines that comes with it week seven is when
we continue alignment and start looking at other things other than the deep neural architectures
so we're going to look at the probabilistic graphical models uh we'll look at different variants of
neural architectures and also reinforcement learning we'll do fusion and new directions
that every year there's some new things and we're packing quite a bit in that and then we have the
midterm it's a few weeks before Thanksgiving and there at that point if you remember you're
implementing the uh presentation the midterm presentation by the way all of the proposal
presentation midterm presentation and final presentation there these deadlines comes in two
parts a report and a presentation itself the report it goes directly to the TA and I and we're
gonna we're gonna we will grade it and give you a lot of feedback but also for the proposal
for the presentation we will use beer feedback we will get feedback from other students
as well for there so for this we'll get other feedback from other students to give you about
your project and the TAs one thing I did not mention each team for their project you will have one TA
which is going to be which will be your primary TA meet as often as you want with your TA
they love working with students on their projects at the minimum you will meet at least three times
at the minimum with each with your primary TA one should be after uh which will be after your
pre-proposal another one which will be around that week after your proposal and another one after
your midterm around that time so it's really important to meet with them as often as you can
and we're also going to create some kind of discussion groups on the on the CADDA if you have
questions and just want to talk with your team and to you there's we have we're we're lucky to
have guest lectures and we're living a lot more space in the last few weeks because the course
project is very central to this and the final project is June Friday so the course grades 16
percent for the lecture participation the reading assignment we're going to give more details about
these two and then the core of it is on the course project itself so what do I mean by lecture
participation and we we spend a lot of time on this to make it useful a training you and also
hopefully don't take too much time so starting next week you don't have to do it for this lecture
and next lecture but starting week number two you will have for every lectures and there's a
total of 20 of these lectures because we have a few time like Thanksgiving and others where there's
no lectures explicitly for the 20 main lectures you have to take what's called a highlight what is
the highlight of that lecture and the highlight the idea is for every 30 minutes or the first 30
minute the next 30 minute and the last 20 minutes ish so it can sometimes I go over so like 20
ish minutes for each of these segments what is the main take home message what is the one sentence
take home message so if you see it should not take so long you should have maybe that google form
it's most likely a google form and just every 30 minutes just write the main or what I would suggest
have another document and just put all your notes when I talk like what is the important thing so
you can revisit later and just write one take home message this take home message cannot be just
keywords that you got from the lecture slides okay it's like the take away cannot be a multimodal
representation or like it should be a full sentence like like a full long sentence of it or a few like
two or three sentences but um optionally what we we realize is we also will have a place for you
to ask questions because it's 120 students it can be very hard for you to ask questions during the
lectures so you can ask question there in this form and any question that we're gonna the deadline
is 42 hours after the lecture so everybody and that also allow you if you're traveling or something
you have 42 hours from the end of the scheduled time so 450 p.m. so you have until 10 40 a.m.
on Thursday to and if it is the Thursday lecture you have 10 40m on Saturday to watch the lecture
and fill that form what we will do is we will grade this little highlight which will be very
lenient as long as it's a summary you can copy we will check if you're too close from other students
so be careful on that but but but the idea also if you write the questions we will do our best to
answer as many of them now we don't know this is the first time we do this if we end up with 2000
answers or not that I don't know how many I don't know if we're gonna be able to so we're we're
looking at option to look at popular and questions to answer them but we'll do as much as we can to
answer them either on Piazza or during the next lecture if for some reason we did not manage to
answer your question at any point in time use Piazza to ask any other follow-up questions this is the
place to use that so this is lecture highlight the reading assignment as I said we really wanted
you to learn a lot while doing as little work as possible not that's not exactly that but I didn't
want you to read three papers you're always welcome to read all three of them I really hope you can
but at the minimum I want you to read one in depth enough that you are able to create a summary
and answer questions from the other students and so the idea here you have a study group of nine
or ten students I think that we created them already or they will be created soon on Piazza
and then you will have a discussion on the Piazza about the papers and so you can use this discussion
for two four two things one is ask question about the paper you read because maybe because you
have other people who read it and then the other one is is to ask question about the other papers
that they're for the first week we're trying something we are not forcing people we're not
assigning people on papers what it means is we you have a study group of nine or ten people
and we will let it to you to pick whichever paper you want with the hope that it is uniformly
distributed if it does not work then the backup is we will assign people randomly to papers and then
you can help each other so we're trying your first version so the idea here is the grade will be
about the reading assignment like your summary that you created and also the discussion we expect
that you at least participated twice you have details instructions for the lecture ally and the
reading assignment really soon on Piazza so the last part of this is I'm going to give you the
pointers because nowadays days it's impossible to get we use canvas in a very limited way I will say
so so the the canvas okay next okay we'll be okay yeah I will tell you about this answer
oh there was a question recently I got but I will answer that in a second so the the canvas is zoom
and piazza and great scope all of it the links are there and also all the recorded sessions
will be on the canvas it will be in something called panacto recordings we'll put them as soon
as we can within a few hours of the class also zoom is what we use now for all the line
and panacto is for the offline version so the panacto is what we'll use for that
and the both the links are both are on canvas in Piazza this is probably the core of what we
will use we'll use Piazza for any announcement any questions you have and then the reading
assignment also we'll use that as well like the study groups will put on the project instruction
and course syllabus the great scope is what we use to when you have your project assignment
reports this is where you will submit this and we also created external course website
this one has a lot of the same information as you see on Piazza but this is a course website that
is accessible by all students and also there's a version of the lectures that will be put there
this is a version of the lecture with being sure that any personal information anything
that could be linked by any current student will be removed and then to be sure that external
course the the external course version is only the thing that that's me talking about things
that's that's what they're okay and I know there is currently about 70 plus people on the waitlist
and a lot of you wants to be in the course the good news is that there will be the spring semester
we have a new edition of the multimodal machine learning previously if you didn't get it in the
fall you had to wait the next fall the next year you're not in this will be teaching the multimodal
machine learning I will not be teaching but I will probably do want to guess lecture I'm sure
but the spring so if it's the same course it's probably going to be a better version
because you bring some new version new new ideas to this so spring if you can do it
we have the version in this so the last slide I have the two last slides I have right now no
this is the last slide so for do you have one homework we're gonna we will post the the details
soon but yes one homework is a project preferences you'll get more you'll get more details in a little
bit about this probably on cad it will be different here on cadza but you have to do this by Tuesday
and we will have more details about the topics and everything there